les vrais complots et glisse est le pire
ennemi de l' enquête sérieuse de complot
c'est la pensée conspirationnistes parce
que on n'a jamais découvert un complot
parce que quelqu'un a dit oh mon dieu
quelqu'un at elle intérêt je suis sûr
que c'est lui dont on aligne des preuves
ont fait des recherches
on prend du temps on questionne de
vandalisme et le conférence à nice mais
ça existe aussi on a des gens qui
aujourd'hui j'en ai plein ma conducteur
qui disent vous êtes trop nu vous êtes
en pls parce qu'on avait raison
on le savait et quand on demande quoi
avait dit de regarder les feux de celle
xml de défaut de chiffres
voilà c'est la preuve qu'un scandale et
quand comment pourquoi qu'est ce que
dedans ben ils disent allez regardez
vous même et les gens pètent sont
tellement sûr que quand quelqu'un leur
dis qu'il ya un scandale parce que les
démêle ont fui en fuite et ils cherchent
même pas à les vérifier quoi ils sont
sales et rassure ça leur fait plaisir
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient eu raison et
en gros 1,6 a des gens qui sont devant
leur télé comme devant une télé réalité
qu'on dit e ou devant le clud au delà
je pense que c'est c'est lui quelques de
becker le noir ils n'ont aucune idée qu
à la fin quand le film avance des
hypothèses avancées super contente
d'avoir dit que c'était lui parce que là
on croirait que c'est lui et là et donc
c'est des gens qui sont très passif et
qu'ils prennent position en temps comme
ça de manière par rapport à leur
ressenti par rapport à leurs billets et
on est tous visés et donc moi le premier
on peut faire attention mais en fait un
juge bien trop vite
les gens sont très prompts à prendre
position pour ou contre ceux ci et après
sans se rendre compte
ils s'engagent eux mêmes et ils
s'empêche de penser contre les armes
pour peut-être aller parce que pour rien
donc il nous faut des enquêteurs si
monsieur mais peut l'espérer a raison
c'est très important qu'ils puissent le
dire je suis content que ça se passe
mais il faudra plus que caricaturer les
positions des uns et des autres on a
tous intérêt à découvrir la vérité dans
il ya des exceptions il ya des gens qui
vont y perdre mais là on a tous intérêt
à ce que la vérité éclate évitant de
prendre ceux qui pensent différemment
pour des idiots
[Musique]